[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous accueillir et
bertha si vous êtes un directeur heureux
là depuis 2015
dans cet endroit unique qu'on va avoir
l'occasion bien sûr d'explorer alors en
tout bien tout honneur parce qu'on
n'aura pas la prétention en près de
cinquante minutes de faire le tour mais
franchement ça vaut le détour ça vaut le
détour aussi que je vous présente celui
qui est à côté de vous parce que vous le
connaissez bien vous hubert vous l'avez
fait venir du sud jusqu'à chez nous on
va tout de suite entendre son accent
bonjour dominique landucci oui bonjour
pascal je suis très heureux d'être à
dassa lino je suis scénographe du
spectacle d'été luxe à l'ina et je suis
là pour les répétitions et le spectacle
va démarrer le 20 juillet oui oui alors
certains se disent c'est bizarre c'est à
lhassa qui nous font ce matin avec le
vent on n'est pas à perros guirec on est
bien à la saline royale d'arc et senans
ici sous le soleil mais avec un peu de
vent ce vendredi matin voilà il faut
faire avec
parfois d'ailleurs dans ce jardin c'est
plus compliqué nicolas bonjour nouveau
stade c'est compliqué dans le jardin on
vous connais vous nicolas les jardiniers
par contre ce qu'on connaît moins c'est
peut-être le paillage le tressage et et
la sciure
parce que ici il ya des jardins
éphémères extraordinaire qu'on va
découvrir avec florence d'ici quelques
minutes mais il ya aussi des
démonstrations qui nous avait réservé
voilà on va faire de petites
démonstrations de choses qu'on retrouve
dans les jardins qu'on peut
effectivement reproduire chez soi
je parlais de ce monument qui est un
monument unique au monde
hubert qu'est ce que vous dites c'est ce
qu'ils nous rejoignent et qui peut-être
entendre parler pour la première fois
parce que je ne sais pas il ne savait
pas que ce site était inscrit par
exemple au patrimoine mondial unesco
qu'est ce que vous leur dites pour les
convaincre de venir ici faire un petit
tour et un détour par la saline royale
d'arc et senans
alors déjà vous parliez de des choix de
ce site de claude nicolas ledoux de
l'architecte qui l'a choisie au xviiie
siècle
il a choisi parce qu avait du vent donc
c'est parfait parfait parfait
effectivement pas c'était un site
d'exploitation du sel dont vous
maintenant il reste peu de traces de ce
passé manufacturier est en tout cas
c'est un ensemble unique vous l'avais
dit à une architecture en ce bâtiment 2
ha 8 de toiture 10 hectares de
de paysages construits par nicolas
ledoux au xviiie siècle et il en a fait
un pas les eaux plutôt qu une
manufacture oui alors tout est sorti de
la tête de ce cerveau d'ailleurs de cet
architecte extraordinaire et et
visionnaire un personnage haut en
couleur vous allez pouvoir le vérifier
et puis nous revenons ensemble ici à la
saline royale d'arc et senans claude
nicolas ledoux est un ingénieur et
urbaniste de talent qui par
l'originalité de ses conceptions fut
considéré comme un des plus grands
architectes de son temps
[Musique]
c'est à paris qu'il fait une grande
partie de sa carrière
parmi ces bâtiments les plus célèbres
les portes de l'octroi qui ont horaires
la capitale de nombreuses habitations de
luxe et des édifices publics comme le
théâtre et de besançon beaucoup de ces
travaux ont disparu aujourd'hui son
chantier le plus remarquable est celui
de la saline d'arc-et-senans dans le
doubs il est conçu une usine de
production de celle d'un nouveau genre
qui ont dans un même lieu se trouvaient
les ateliers industriels les habitations
des ouvriers la maison du directeur et
des jardins pour tout le monde
l'architecte rêver même de prolonger le
demi-cercle de la saline et de
construire une cité idéale où les
habitants vivraient dans la concorde et
la fraternité
une ville utopistes qui ne joue jamais
le jour il est vrai que lorsque l'on
arrive par la route du côté de cette
solide on a l'impression que ça émerge
un petit peu de terre c'est un petit peu
le passage dans un autre monde
il ya une commun un théâtre antique là
qui surgit de nulle part finalement
hubert sacy
c'est vrai cette cité est posée là au
milieu d'un espace effectivement un peu
probable en plein milieu de la nature
cet ensemble construit avec cette
architecture très puissante
donc c'est l'effet était voulue par le
doubs s'est pas fait par hasard il a
vraiment choisi le lieu il a vraiment
déterminé la construction de cette salle
in qui est construite effectivement un
peu comme un cadran solaire
c'est un lieu d'utopie un finalement
alors certes il ya beaucoup de vent mais
la saline royale d'arc et senans avec ou
sans le vent c'est quand même avant tout
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
parce que pour l'époque c'était
extraordinaire il faut dire que tout le
monde vivait ici il y avait plusieurs
centaines d'ouvriers qui étaient là avec
le patron
et tout le reste alors oui effectivement
on peut pas vraiment parler d'utopie au
moment où claude nicolas ledoux
construit sa saleen puisque c'est très
concret construit une manufacture de sel
vous l'avez dit avec les en pensant au
travail des ouvriers qui seront situés
donc sur le lieu de travail de
production en pensant aussi leur
bien-être en construisant des jardins
ouvriers tout autour de la saline les
conditions de travail il faut pas se
leurrer était quand même assez rude 12
heures par jour
donc c'était les deux fois douze heures
effectivement avec des conditions de
travail assez dur mais malgré tout pour
l'époque effectivement les ouvriers
étaient logés sur place et avait un
début d'organisation sociale avec des
indemnités en cas d'accident en tout cas
c'était c'était prévu donc c'était une
amélioration par rapport à l'époque oui
alors à l'époque c'était 6 ou par jour
on n'était pas aux 35 heures évidemment
peu le pas bien compris c'était près de
250 personnes qui travaillaient vraiment
j'insiste en vase clos chaque matin il y
avait la chapelle la messe obligatoire
le directement le contremaître enfin il
y avait toute une hiérarchie qui s'était
mise là d'ailleurs ça se traduit par la
maison du pouvoir et la maison du
directeur qui est assez imposante et
qu'on peut voir ici justement dans cette
sale in wii qui est situé juste derrière
nous effectivement le doubs voulait
marquer la présence du roi en tant que
c'est la maison du directeur c'est la
maison laprise la présence du rpt du
pouvoir royal effectivement ça devait
impressionné c'était aussi un monument
dédié à la connaissance ce le triangle
que l'on voit percer d'oculus claude
nicolas ledoux était franc-maçon donc on
retrouve des symboles maçonniques à
travers sa construction
et c'était aussi l'oeil de la
connaissance et pas simplement celui de
la surveillance
on va les découvrir une exposition d'ici
quelques secondes consacré un autre
architecte visionnaire un certain luc
vous pensez comme en skate hollandaise
d'accord ok maintenant je voudrais qu'on
revienne sur le classement unesco en
1982 parce que ça a forcément fait
évoluer les choses ou bertha si vous
avez vu passer des milliers de personnes
supplémentaires oui alors ça c'était un
choix très
effectivement important qui avait été
fait par serge antoine le président de
l'époque de faire classer la saline à
l'époque y avait très peu de monuments
aujourd'hui on est à peu près autour de
1063 monuments classés à travers le
monde à l'époque c'était très peu donc
1982 un des premiers monuments classés
la valeur universelle de ce bien et est
reconnue au titre de son de son
architecture 200 architectes et aussi du
patrimoine industriel très bien très
bien alors l'industrie c'est une chose
les jardins c'en est une autre
il ya des jardins éphémères qu'on va les
découvrir le temps peut-être aussi pour
nicolas de se mettre en place d'ici
quelques minutes pour nous préparer une
petite démo vous allez aussi nous faire
découvrir
hubert cette fameuse exposition l'expo
2100 pour savoir finalement à quoi
ressembleront nos villes la planète et
pourquoi pas arc et senans au siècle
prochain mais d'abord florence et là
tout sourire dans un des trois jardins
qu'on va visiter ce matin où êtes-vous
jardin j'allais dire à florence oui
c'est florence où êtes-vous florence on
va y arriver
pascal on va rentrer dans le vif du
sujet dans l'univers des jardins
associés à l'oeuvre de luxe cotelle avec
vous denis duquet puisque vous êtes
responsable de ce festival des jardins
ici on est dans ce qu'on appelait ça le
la nature alors vous pouvez nous parler
déjà de la nature alors c'est vrai qu'on
est dans un jardin très particulier on
l'appelle le jardin jungle donc c'est un
jardin jungle où on n'a pas hésité à
mélanger beaucoup de végétaux différents
donc dans un premier temps on a une
marque est très présente dans lequel il
ya énormément de vie on a des tifa en
bordure de cette marre on va trouver un
petit jardin quelque part de plantes
aromatiques qui peut servir pour la
cuisine ben voilà il va servir pour la
cuisine des gens qui habiteront à
proximité de ce jardin là on va aller on
a un effet y est donc un arbre fruitier
et puis si on se retourne
on va voir qu'on a également un surhomme
un don qui est une espèce indigène qui
est très intéressant pour la
biodiversité et qui peut aussi servir
pour la cuisine d'ailleurs je peux
servir pour faire des confitures naquit
fondé de confiture du sérum et les
fleurs sont intéressantes pour les
pollinisateurs et les fruits pour pour
les oiseaux et puis là on retrouve
encore quelques petits fruitiers et puis
là voilà on a des petits fruits sains
des myrtilles arbustives
et voilà c'est un petit peu
l'originalité de ce jardin on n'hésite
pas à tout mélanger
donc ce jardin se déroule autour eux
d'une d'une maison d'un habitat quel est
il
alors c'est une carter donc c'est une
maison bien particulière qui nous vient
de bretagne qui est douce et non voilà
qui a été imaginé par evelyne adam est
celle ci ben c'est une première en
france puisque c'est la rencontre de luc
schuiten et de evelyne adam qui ont
abouti à cette construction avant de
rentrer dedans y'a quand même ça cette
petite plante que vouliez me montrer
tout à l'heure qu'est ce que c'est
voilà alors c'est une plante qui est
très connu dans notre région des
agriculteurs et qu'ils aillent en
allemand larache ça on essaye absolument
de s'en débarrasser le rumex et c'est
une plante voilà qui gêne pour
faire sécher les foins et ici on la
garde parce que evelyne adam nous
explique que toutes les plantes ont leur
utilité et que ce remake cela en fait et
nous permet de décompacter le sol en
profondeur
beaucoup de plantes voilà autour de
scènes d'habitat alors on vient sur la
construction de cette carter en quoi
est-ce fabriqués alors cette carter elle
est fabriquée à l'origine c'est
uniquement du clash de la chaux du
chanvre et du sable et c'est le chanvre
qui avec sa résistance de ces fibres qui
va donner la solidité à la construction
donc là mais vous avez rajouté une
petite structure quand même
exceptionnellement voilà on avait une
contrainte de temps pour la construction
est une contrainte de forme aussi donc
on a réalisé une structure à base de
larmes de bambou qui nous ont permis de
monter l'ensemble de la de la structure
ensuite en une semaine avec bull monde
avec beaucoup beaucoup de bénévoles
c'est un projet participatif est alors
atteint on pourrait habiter dedans alors
à terme le twitter n'a décidé à dessiner
vraiment l'intérieur de la carter dans
lequel on doit retrouver tous les toutes
les pièces d'une maison aussi bien ici
dans la salle de bain avec la douche les
toilettes le petit coin salon le coin
cuisine et puis la table pour manger et
à les étages s'ils n'ont pu dire un
petit couchage et un poil pour assurer
le chauffage pour l'hiver et comment
vous baser les relations entre la maison
et le jardin
l'idée c'est que c'est un habitat qui
est bonifiant pour l'extérieur
donc vous avez vu avec cette approche du
jardin ben en fait on va avoir un écrin
qui sera très riche en biodiversité
et si vous écoutez on entend les
grenouilles qui sont en train de chanter
donc c'est bien la preuve que je ne
raconte pas d'issue premières habitantes
dix lieux en tout cas ça c'est un
endroit qui va rester au delà du
festival oui et on continue notre
exploration dans les endroits plus
éphémère dans quelques instants pascal
nous retrouverons évidemment florence
dans les jardins extraordinaires de la
saline dont les réalisations appelons
libertas y court jusqu'au mois d'octobre
ça va nous laisser le temps quand même
de pouvoir aller encore s'y balader
d'ici la fin de cette émission mais là
on poursuit avec cette exposition
magique avec un architecte visionnaire
ou sommes-nous précisément ici vers oui
alors nous avons les grands formats de
l'exposition lux cayton dans cette berne
qui était le lieu de production du sel
au xviiie siècle faut imaginer ici à 50°
100 % d'humidité 24 heures sur 24
aujourd'hui donc c'est un lieu dévolu
aux expositions et de grands formats
comme vous pouvez le voir autour de nous
un d ça nous permet effectivement
d'exposer des oeuvres monumentales et en
particulier cet espace jour nuit où on
vit en cinq minutes le rythme d'une
journée de 24 heures
on va découvrir plus en détails d'ici
quelques secondes cette exposition
consacrée à luxe cayenne
on ne dira jamais assez un architecte
visionnaire dont la réflexion peut sur
quoi finalement parce que là on voit
quelques en géorgie mais mais où
sommes-nous qu'est-ce qui se passe oui
alors l'exclu t1 effectivement déjà
pourquoi la saline luxe carlton vous
l'avez dit c'est un architecte
visionnaire scène architectes utopistes
et il est très proche de l'esprit de
claude nicolas ledoux qui était le
créateur de la saline royale le doubs
disait lorsqu'on détruit des taux 10 ans
redonne à l'homme sa dignité et skytone
aujourd'hui construit des abris pour les
sdf
donc c'est vrai que c'était cette
filiation qui nous avait un semblait
importante de montrer et puis tout chez
lui et du développement durable
comme ces machines effectivement on
envoie une extraordinaire lectrique avec
la force humaine puisque c'est ça marche
au pédalage alors on n'a pas pour des
raisons de temps vous l'aurez compris ce
vendredi matin la possibilité de de
pédaler en revanche on peut remonter le
temps ça c'est la magie de la télévision
figurez-vous que luxe cayenne
nous l'avions rencontré justement il y a
quelques années
regardez et nous revenons ensemble ici
pour cette matinale tout à fait spéciale
depuis arc et senans à la saline
luc skytone invente des cités végétales
des rues avec des habits tard ou des
logements organique des vies ou l'homme
abondent les trottoirs pour coloniser
les toits respirer l'air et créer des
potagers dans l'idée d'une société qui
aurait très très fort évoluer on aurait
quitté d'abord société de consommation
où on travaille pour produire et payer
pour consommer et puis peut rejeter tout
ce qui est tout ce qu on en utilise pas
où sa sortie de cette frénésie pour être
beaucoup plus juste par rapport à nos
besoins réels et pour se déplacer dans
une époque où le pétrole aura disparu
notre metteur en scène de rêve s'inspire
des animaux nos avions
désormais au plana ailes battantes en
fête des anges en aérien qui captent
l'énergie solaire un mode de transport
bien éloigné de nos avions à réaction
pour vol à 1000km refus les nuages
naples perception on n'est plus en
contact avec cry devil sans pollution
d'où l'on aperçoit les montagnes des
vies où la nature est en équilibre avec
l'homme des villes vertes sans verre
imaginez qu'un mélange du jaune avec du
bleu même si je la décompose et ici on
pouvait imaginer le vert versé n'est
finalement que du jaune du bleu mélange
et si l'udc dessine souvent ces cités
végétales vue du ciel c'est parce que
c'est un adepte des ultra léger motorisé
c'est pour ça que souvent mais vu
sentent aérienne c'est pour redonner
l'horizon aux gens c'est pour ça que
j'utilise les toitures en tant que
jardin et que promenade 7,7
manière aussi doit donner cette
respiration
[Musique]
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
le parti pris de la scénographie sur
cette exposition ici c'est l'optimisme
hubert finalement oui alors voit
effectivement vous avez raison pascal qu
on trouve aussi un petit peu genre non à
ses collègues dessinateur auteur
d'anticipation l'udc est optimiste voilà
il voit pas un futur post-apocalyptique
après un tremblement de terre ou une une
catastrophe nucléaire il imagine comment
prendre conscience des risques que court
la planète et que les hommes vont
construire des cités qui vont se
rapprocher de la nature avec des
architectures biomimétique comme il dit
donc d'où ces immeubles effectivement
qui ressemble à des arbres oui on voit
ça y'a vraiment le parti pris aussi de
l'éco durable on va les voir un petit
peu ce qui se passe parce que
franchement on est on est dans quelque
chose et moi je vais le dire d'utopistes
quand même alors à la fois c'est
utopiste et récemment on a vu que dans
des villes comme dubai ou même à new
york
on commence à implanter des jardins sur
les toits des potagers à dubaï les
immeubles ressemblent à des arbres donc
quelque part cet optimisme prend aussi
s'ancre dans le présent l'objectif c'est
quoi finalement c'est la réaction des
visiteurs c'est un électrochoc
cette exposition ici à la saline royale
d'arc et senans je pense que si on fait
prendre conscience effectivement d'une
certaine nécessité à à changer notre
mode de vie
en tout cas c'est ce que souhaite luxe
carlton depuis 40 ans ils prêchent 7
cette philosophie là depuis le début
et petit à petit c'est vrai qu'il ya une
prise de conscience des gens et on voit
l'intérêt des visiteurs effectivement
pour cette philosophie la nature et
architecture ce sont les trois mots
finalement qui résume très modestement
cette exposition qu'on peut voir ici
oui c'est un bon résumé alors il est
vrai que en même temps on peut aussi
apprendre pour les enfants par exemple à
découvrir ces cités du futur pour
l'instant ce ne sont que des rêves
malgré tout il ya quelques pistes qui
sont aujourd'hui explorer oui lui qui
tenait donc il ya des espaces
pédagogiques dans cette berne qui
permettent aux enfants de 6 ans amusant
de prendre conscience effectivement des
nécessités du développement durable et
de l'impact qu'a l'homme sur la planète
c'est vraiment le combat de luxe layton
et il le fait avec délicatesse et beauté
à travers ses oeuvres ses dessins hubert
il a dû franchement beaucoup s'amuser
aussi luxe capitaine parce que si on se
retourne et et qu'on regarde ce jardin
oeuvre
ah oui quand même surpris si nous
l'annoncions thorel oui alors ça je suis
pas sûr que ça fonctionne en réalité la
cerner vraiment dans l'utopie mais en
tout cas l utopie est belle il ya un
côté icare dans cette heure dans cette
oeuvre effectivement et c'est se
rapprocher du soleil mais pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas alors bon à défaut de se
rapprocher du soleil on va garder toute
la lumière ce matin en continuant votre
visite dans ces jardins extraordinaires
avec florence qu'on va aller retrouver
puis juste après c'est notre jardinier à
nous que vous connaissez bien nicolas le
jardinier qui va nous donner quelques
conseils pour par exemple le paillage
vous savez faire du paillage vous ab
j'observe les hommes on va le faire
ensemble ce matin
restez avec nous sur france 3 pascal on
a changé d'univers ici on est dans le
jardin d
mr jean vente parlé avec marie perrin
parce qu'elle a imaginé beaucoup de
choses oui parce que denis duquet tout
ça en fait c'est la collaboration à des
dizaines de personnes pendant des
semaines
oui alors pour chaque jardin il ya
beaucoup d'écoles qui sont présentes à
la saline sur ce jardin là on avait le
laisser de fées bio qui a été présent
pendant une semaine donc de 20 20 jeunes
de bac pro qui ont participé à la
réalisation du jardin imaginé par marie
alors marc et qu'est ce que vous avez
voulu ici dans les émergents
donc avec megan que mon ami et
paysagistes ont
on a travaillé sur la cité des vagues de
luke schenn qui est une cité qui est qui
s'adapte aux l'arbre est donc nous on
s'est posé la question de comment on vit
en haut des arbres et donc avant de
monter jusqu'à la cime des arbres
on rentre dans cette cabane on vient
s'installer au creux des arbres et pour
mieux monter entre les arbres on monte
sur la canopée
voilà on est parti pour la canopée donc
cette structure-là a été fait avec les
les élèves de fées bio c'est une
structure qui nous a pris pas mal de
temps mais qui est assez et qui vaut le
coup ou voilà qui fait son effet avant
d'arriver dans la canopée
on peut se balancer une vraie malle en
selle d'arbre en arbre comme les comme
les singes les écureuils on dépend de
l'humeur du jour c'est important on voit
là on ne doit pas juste frôlé ces objets
faut les occuper fond mais l'inversé un
jardin à vivre où on peut s'asseoir dans
la cabane on peut se déplacer on peut se
balancer sauter plus tard avec les
bascules
on va y aller et tout ça en admirant la
cime des arbres
là ce sont des arbres qui étaient déjà
là évidemment voilà les frênes qu'on
peut voir et les catalpas était là et
donc en fait pour la conception on avait
déjà l'idée de la canopée et quand on
est revenu sur le site pour pour
enrichir notre dessein on a pris en
compte tout l'existant donc tous ces
arbres toutes les plantes toutes les
vivas keitel a déjà et la butte qui ici
alors pour jouer toujours le côté
hautain il ya même un belvédère
voilà ce belvédère nous a été suggérée
par les vanniers qui ont réalisé tout
les tous les dom en sol et donc réaliser
toujours avec les les élèves pendant la
semaine de chantier qui a été une super
semaine et pendant cette semaine de
chantier il ya des allers retours entre
vous vous discutez parfois faut tempérer
certaine folie où ça se passe
globalement dans le dialogue
ça s'est très très bien passé mais
effectivement un projet tel que celui ci
s'est aussi beaucoup de discussions
beaucoup de concessions entre les
concepteurs les étudiants qui sont là
qui sont aussi fortes
position les enseignants également et
puis l'équipe de la saline des
jardiniers qui ont aussi le recul sur
sur certains aménagements alors on
continue dans le ludique parce que vous
ne parliez des bascules mamie on va
aller faire un tour de sueur j'essaie de
ne pas tomber au milieu donc toujours
des réalisations en osier voilà qui sont
assez qui font leur effet enzo 6 allez-y
passe en premier parce que moi je vais
attendre de voir comment ça marche un os
ça va falloir dangereux et et on s'amuse
dans ses jardins c'est aussi l'idée d'un
jardin à les données révélées
qu'est ce que ça vous apporte vous de
travailler sur un chantier comme le
festival des jardins à la saline
d'enchaîner sur un cvc bien oui oui il
ya déjà le fait d'avoir été choisi
et surtout c'est tout le côté suivi de
chantier on a quand même eu deux écoles
les charpentiers aussi qu'ils nous ont
dessiné la cabane et donc il faut
écouter toutes ces personnes là il faut
prendre en compte leur avis aussi parce
qu'elles sont elles sont importantes on
avait des botanistes aussi qui nous ont
aidés pour toute la palette végétale et
vous n'étiez pas venu depuis plusieurs
semaines et alors comment allait sa main
basse et à c'est assez génial
toutes les plantes ont pris les
grimpantes commence à pousser sur sur
les structures en sol c'est c'est super
chouette c'est super chouette trois
quilles en moi et c'est très bien comme
comme qualificatif voilà parce qu'elles
font ce deuxième jardin on se retrouve
évidemment tout à l'heure avec les
vanniers pour parler un petit peu plus
du travail de l'osier florence et ses
invités ont visiblement la main verte on
va nous aussi vous faire quelques
expériences autour de l'osier mais
d'abord on va s'inspirer du lieu nicolas
le jardinier parce que vous êtes venus
ici avec nous ce matin arc et senans
pour nous aider et c'est vrai que quand
on se promène ici on se rend compte que
d aller un petit peu particulière et ce
qu'on ne sait pas c'est que c'est du
paillage tout à fait il ya donc des
allées qui ont un aspect très moelleux
c'est très agréable au marché c'est très
sain de l'ordinaire donc c'est allé
effectivement sont réalisés de la sueur
il faut y penser c'est des matériaux de
récupération qui sont tout simple à
utiliser il ya deux-trois petites de
trois petites techniques d'être un petit
conseil à savoir avant de la vendre les
reproduire
la maison en même temps vous nous en
parler on va quelques images sur ses
allées donc en sciure de chêne ça limite
les mauvaises herbes pourquoi les 6 rue
du chêne d'abord au peu de figures
déchaînement ça va libérer du tana qui
va un petit peu limité le développement
des mauvaises herbes ça va brûler dès
qu'elles ont commencé à germer le tannat
va tout va brûler ccc ces graines donc
du coup ça va vraiment limité donc on
aura vraiment un aspect toujours propre
danse dans ces années il à ceux qui sont
avec nous ce matin se disent ok il est
très gentil mais bon si nicolas a fait
le déplacement c'est quand même pour
nous montrer quelque chose
voilà alors bon s'il vous plaît comme en
photo ses fameuses aller en sciure pour
ceux qui sont avec nous et qui
souhaiteraient le faire déjà est ce que
ça coûte cher premièrement non parce que
la plupart du temps ça peut être des
matériaux de récupération donc si on
fait par exemple si on fait du chauffage
au bois à la maison on peut récupérer
cette sueur et puis ensuite les métros
rempaillage on dans les allées d'accord
alors déjà très bon plan ça coûte pas
cher maintenant s'il vous plaît venu
avec le matériel d'enfer il ya dominique
derrière qui est scénographe qu'on va
retrouver dans quelques minutes qui
allaitent origines d'un spectacle
extraordinaire ici sur cette saline
royale d'arc et senans île verte acides
des recteurs qui nous regardent un peu
comme des extraterrestres ils se disent
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font là alors
qu'est ce que c'est que ça expliquez moi
voilà déjà on a une structure de pour
apprendre un petit peu apprécié pour
essayer de reproduire certaines choses
quand on peut donc fait que l'on voit
dans les jardins dans tout l'est tout ce
qui était fait dans les jardins ont été
faits par des écoles donc notamment pour
les élèves de l'école de file bio en
champagne ardenne bien sûr la
comparaison
on va essayer donc de reproduire un
petit peu dans des structures non
également fait une reproduction donc une
petite coupe un petit peu de d'aller en
rang sur pour montrer un petit peu
comment comment on peut réaliser sa dont
vous voulez les allemands sur donc on a
donc bon tout d'abord donc on a moins le
solde soit naturel que j'espère qu'on la
voit là parce qu'il ya beaucoup de vent
ici et c'est vrai que c'est pas
forcément très très mal décaissé
d'environ dix centimètres ont retiré
donc la terre ensuite on a donc rajouté
donc on va donc faire un petit mélange
de terre et de sueur donc sur environ 5
6 cm donc environ moitié moitié sur
moitié-moitié terre on mélange bien le
bien ensemble et donc pour finir donc la
couche de finition a donc mettre environ
3 cm 2 de sueur pour finir donc de sueur
de copeaux donc on va toujours travaillé
en dôme
donc le fait d'avoir un mélange ici ça
va donc permettre de drainer si on met
uniquement de la sueur sur de la terre
bon alors ce qu'ils on aura des gros
intempéries la sueur va partir alors que
si on fait déjà ce ménage surtout le
ster plus ensuite la terre donc lolo va
donc s'infiltre et va donc freiner et ça
évitera donc d'akira du vent ou des que
dès qu'il ya des grosses roches évitera
que tout parte
donc si je résume mélange de sciure de
terre est comme ça ça draine ça va
drainer et ensuite en surface on a donc
remettre une finition en sur super moi
j'ai mon allée à aussillon maintenant il
ya le tressage ici j'ai bossé très doux
et encore je peux même vous tenir le
micro ainsi voilà qu'après mail séance à
dilma allez on y va
voilà donc ok voulons que ça peut servir
et moi ça c'est donc de l'osier sec
ils étaient trempés pendant plusieurs
jours pour éviter qu'une soit location
très compliqué hein vous parlais tout à
l'heure de fayl billot 1 c'était que
l'extraordinaire en région champagne
ardenne on apprend justement à faire des
pallières décidé les paniers d'osier oui
parce que losier jacuzzi et du dossier
sept dossiers sec donc fait donc là on
va donc regarder pour faire des des
tressages pour limiter pour séparer dans
des allées avec des massifs
donc après donc le la chose est donc on
va on va presser tout tout seul tout
simplement rentrés sains vont partir
comme ça si j'avais trois mains mais je
peux pas je me donne pas la pieuvre
encore mais ça sera pas présent à
l'audience donc été plusieurs jours dans
l'eau pour éviter qu'ils soient trop
cassant parce qu'autrement on
n'arriverait pas à faire des structures
comme ça et donc ça casserait vraiment
très facilement d'accord donc du coup
voilà on au quai
on passe d'un d'appliquer un autre on
alterne à chaque fois et on trouve ton
du bo n'osiez comme ça là on peut
retrouver bon bain
il ya différents endroits on peut
retrouver notamment sur surfaces bio qui
est vraiment la capitale de l'osier la
capitale de la vannerie donc on trouve
différents différents types d'osier et
donc là c'est donc de l'osier c'est
qu'après la douzième vivant où on peut
faire on préfère des structures malo de
nous y vivent sera plantée dans la terre
ensuite ça travailler donc le losier
aura donc des cadeaux aux il y aura donc
des feuilles
ouais alors que la bon là se désiste nos
essais qu aucun rapport avec la terre il
sera pas racine et donc on n'aura pas de
la pâte feuilles de sucer des structures
qui vont durer environ deux ans etb
parfait on a moins de deux ans
maintenant à passer ensemble on a
quelques minutes encore pour vous
montrer des magnifiques jardins des
jardins extraordinaires
charles trenet aurait pu chanter
d'ailleurs que c'est un jardin
extraordinaire
il y en a deux tellement tellement
extraordinaire je vais vous emmener dans
l'un des plus grands festivals de jardin
direction chaumont-sur-loire histoire de
bien déconnecté avant de revenir ici à
la saline royale d'arc et senans pour ce
vendredi matin sous le soleil avec un
vent formidable c'est le vent de la
bonne humeur j'allais presque 11 euros
prend le noir infinie philippe et ses
petits enfants ont découvert les jardins
de chaumont ce matin une expérience qui
allie nature les réflexions donc mais
l'été est ce qu'elle vous inspire
qu'est-ce que vous inspire ça te fait
penser à quoi
parmi la trentaine de jardins
sélectionnés voici le fil et de la
pensée il symbolise comment en cours et
à partir du 14e siècle les hommes en
exil utiliser la pensée pour s'évader
une pêche symbolique pour capturer le
temps c'est des cannes à pêche et
les plaintes violette ça fait penser aux
poissons et il est pierre ça fait penser
à l'eau tient donne aussi la possibilité
à tout le monde de faire libre libre
cours à sa création à son inventivité et
regardez les les panneaux métalliques
ici ça me rappelle beaucoup musée de
bilbao qu'est une salle où y'a que ça
c'est vraiment impressionnant
la possibilité d'une île harry potter le
livre de sable cette année le festival
des jardins mais la pensée et donc la
littérature au coeur des créations on
pense au verger de plateaux au jardin
d'epicure promenade des philosophes de
kyoto d'albert
quand on est dans un jardin la pensée se
déroule plus facilement la
caractéristique d'un jardin réussi c'est
un jardin dans lequel on a envie de
rester parce qu'il exerce une influence
sur notre imaginaire le végétal apaise
aux jardins de chaumont il donne aussi à
réfléchir voire à méditer ce domaine
considéré comme l'un des plus beaux
lieux de l'art du jardin au monde vous
invite à une journée de poésie jusqu'à
début novembre
histoire de déconnecter complètement du
monde urbain le temps d'une journée de
la poésie nous ne manquons pas ici aussi
vous l'aurez compris arc et senans dans
cette salle une extraordinaire ce
vendredi matin
d'ailleurs on va continuer la
déambulation dans ses jardins éphémères
avec florence qu'on va les retrouver
avant de parler de spectacle parce
qu'ici il faut le savoir il ya des
milliers de personnes qui se retrouvent
pour un spectacle étonnant on va le
découvrir avec l'un de ses créateurs qui
est avec nous ici pascal c'est notre
dernière incursion dans les jardins ici
précisément le jardin des habitats arbre
alors à quoi ça correspond denis
exactement alors ici les concepteurs
paysagistes ont voulu mettre en
opposition notre monde très urbain très
minéral avec le monde de luc schuiten
qui lui est vraiment une cités végétales
habite et respectueuse de son
environnement
et c'est là qu'on a vraiment un gros
travail de l'école deuxième culture de
vannerie de fayl billot qu'un partenaire
traditionnel mais là cette année ce
grosse édition wii cette année on leur a
demandé un gros effort puisqu'ils sont
venus deux semaines et c'est la 18e fois
qu'ils participent à notre festival
comment ça se passe en fait vous leur
donnez des schémas et puis après traduit
exactement on arrive avec les dessins
des concepteurs et eux immédiatement ils
transcrivent en termes dodier vivant et
ben on va visiter du coup ce jardin vous
pouvez donner votre micro à jean-pierre
benetiere dont vous êtes formateur à
cette école et puis lui s'il vous vous
êtes stagiaire vous avez participé eux
jean-pierre lauzier c'est vraiment un
matériau extrêmement traditionnel
oui c'est un peu un matériau très
traditionnel cultivé depuis fort
longtemps en haute-marne et donc l'école
de vannerie et ça y est enseigne l'art
de très saine aux yeux alors l'art de
tresser losier ça pousse ou losier alors
ça pousse surtout de sur des terrains
humides et c'est une plante qui aime
beaucoup l'os et du sol
c'est une sorte de sol alors là lucile
vous on a une première arche
comment comment vous avez travaillé
dessus alors on s'est basés déjà sur des
arbres qui étaient déjà en place et on a
installé ce qu'on appelle des perche est
donc c'est du sol à la vase qui quand il
est cultivé devient osier et la cdu de
l'osier qui a deux à trois ans donc on
installe complant dans le dans le sol
par mon don de chaque côté et après mon
les traits sont fait en sorte de faire
des arches lors la difficulté c'est de
faire en sorte qu'elles soient
symétriques et qu'elle est une belle
courbe
donc c'est assez facile et pas forcément
pas ressorti à bopa coup d il faut pas
casser
il faut l'accompagner donc c'est un
véritable travail et à partir de là il
faut aussi 20 faire des liens pour que
ça puisse rester en place et donc ces
liens sont aussi faits à base d'eau zié
comme on peut le voir ici
alors là on la plaint on va en voir
détails et un petit peu ces noeuds donc
c'est de l'osier toujours aussi mais
notre partenaire j'imagine voilà donc en
fait on ad on
donc il ya différentes tailles on coupe
losier ont la classe on latry après par
taille et donc les petits brins souvent
on les utilise pour faire des liens
notamment dans les vignes à l'époque
c'était surtout là-bas pour les utiliser
et donc là comme cd perschetz et
beaucoup plus costaud on utilise des
liens un peu plus gros voilà et l'ours
et non parce que en effet ça se fond
complètement dans le paysage c'est
évident dans la pression qu'il ya des
arches que d'un coup il ya quelque chose
de très harmonieux très symétrique au
milieu de la forêt jean pierre c'est ça
l'idée oui c'était ça c'était ce qui
était intéressant dont jardin c'était
d'utiliser les plans qui était en place
et puis venir agrémenter différents
arche et jusqu'à presque un cloître
comment on appelle ça c'est appeler ça
comme ça et donc l'idée c'était de jouer
avec les lignes ce qui était très
intéressant en les faisant très
régulière hans et savamment organisée
finalement et c'était très intéressant
de réaliser cette structure parce que
déjà c'est assez monumentale et puis
aujourd'hui on la voit en végétation du
coup ça devient un abri très agréable
pour passer un petit moment
lucile qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on
fait après une formation comme ça en
osier riz culture et en vannerie et une
expérience au festival des jardins bas
on n'a qu'une envie c'est de recommencer
à un projet comme celui-ci parce que
c'est vraiment hyper intéressant c'est
des projets que qui ne vient pas de nous
enfin qu'on n'a pas créé et donc mettre
en pratique réalisé en fait
comment dire un projet d'une autre
personne c'est assez intéressant servira
pour votre voilà on apprend en continu
en comptait vingt être artisan
voilà je voudrais être daniel mais aussi
aux agricultrices pour cultiver mon
propre rozier voilà pour pouvoir
travailler ma matière première ben voila
c'était un autre notre zoom sur losier
ici au festival des jardins en
absolument surtout les jardins je ne
peux que vous encourager à les parcourir
un parra avec encore plus de temps qu'on
n'y a pas c'est parce que c'est un
délice merci florence je vous propose de
se retrouver dans quelques minutes
france pour aller un petit une petite
faim sympathique mais juste avant je
faisais quand même dominique qu'on
s'intéresse à ce spectacle j'allais dire
populaire festif qui se déroule ici dans
ce cadre bien particulier de la saline
royale d'arc et senans
j'ai quand même plus de 800 figurants de
la région qui participent à lux salinas
icoa luxe serena à lor lux à l'ina est
un spectacle visuel qui a été commandé
par la cndh royal en la personne
d'hubert thaci qui m'a contacté pour
faire un spectacle événementiel d'été
grand public
racontant une histoire de la saline
décalé et compréhensible par les
étrangers les enfants et surtout pour
europe pour pour accrocher avec le
territoire et faire participer le
maximum de cantois au spectacle et là je
crois qu'on a dépassé toutes les
espérances puisque quand je suis arrivé
en 2015 on m'avait promis une
cinquantaine de personnes bénévoles et
la journée 800 et et le pire c'est que
c'est tous des amis quoi donc je vais
beaucoup de pondre alors le pont pour
ceux qui ne connaissent pas mais dans la
région connaît tous c'est le petit
apéritif de quoi se glisse avec
modération le pastis les versions de
sud/sud-est de lui envoyer ou m6 avec le
maillot au pastis au lit mais je repars
le port le pee porc aux olives
en tout cas c'est une histoire féerique
poétiser en sept tableaux on a du mal à
imaginer où ça se passe ici
tu crois que c'est juste derrière nous
il ya une grille alors c'est derrière
nous ça se passe sur les deux berne est
et ouest et la maison du directeur sur
ses murs ses façades
il y à des projections d'image service
convient dominique mais plutôt que d'en
parler on va regarder quelques images
sur un pré salé avec ta que je crois que
c'est déjà la troisième édition
donc on regarde et en revenir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
il ya une nouveauté cette année le mini
de quoi s'agit-il
alors la grande nouveauté stade et je
suis j'en suis très fier ainsi que je
pense liberta si puisqu'on a déjà
travaillé avec ce grand personnage de de
musique de film il est connu comme ça
c'est bruno coulais de bruno coulais
pour ceux qui connaissent pas c'est le
peuple de l'herbe
voilà c'est surtout le césar de les
gorilles musique en 1997 c'est les
choristes c'est le peuple migrateur où
il a quand même le tenu et c'est l'un
des rares un autre césar en l'an 2000
pour la musique donc si seulement
quelqu'un qui a plus de trente cinq
musiques de films au compteur pour bien
qu'on comprenne les personnes oui un
grand un grand personnage qui a on voit
les grands à leur humilité je crois que
bruay et une définition de grands
personnages de grands musiciens
il est venu voir la première édition en
tant qu ami gilbert le connaît bien
donc il a invité et il a aimé le
spectacle et on lui a proposé de faire
la musique du 2,10 ion 2 il a commencé
la musique de l'édition de hellas
d'année iftar il a terminé toutes les
musiques sont de bruno coulais pour le
spectacle luxe à l'ina édition 3 du 20
juillet au 18 août pour être très précis
ça fait quinze représentations grosso
modo à partir de 22h 36m 22h30 à la
tombée de la nuit
ouais ouais tout à fait tiens puisqu'on
parle de spectacle et c'est aussi ce
lieu une résidence pour les artistes
si je vous dis jordi savall hubert et
oui un compagnonnage avec le grand
musicien catalan et son ensemble concert
des nations depuis trois ans déjà et
pour trois ans encore puisque la
résidence vient d'être prolongée par le
ministère de la culture donc jordi est
dans nos murs il est là plusieurs fois
par par année cinq fois par an et il
sera là le 12 juillet à la saline royale
pour un spectacle en deux parties qui
débutera à 19h 19h 21h 22h minuit la
dent coop sur luc solidaire on joue les
nocturnes
je crois qu'on a aussi quelques images
de jordi savall si je ne me trompe pas
normalement ils devraient être avec nous
au mieux par la pensée mais a priori ça
devrait être en couleurs d'ici la fin de
cette émission
une certitude c'est que voilà c'est
toujours des grands évènements je le
disais un jour 10 aval on en parlait
donc vous pouvez lancer parce qu'on me
dit on lance que tu veux dans
l'oreillette vous pouvez y aller
[Musique]
ans
jordi savall on en a beaucoup parlé sur
france 3 nous l'avons suivi pour un
feuilleton qui a été diffusée cet hiver
à revoir sur france 3 point fr et
pourquoi pas aussi à ça vous réussit à
la saline royale d'arc et senans
libertas et oui effectivement comme je
vous le disais le prochain concert c'est
bien 12 juillet donc à la saline royale
il y aura aussi un grand concert le 14
octobre
vivaldi vie judy triomphante une pièce
rarement donné un oratorio de vivaldi ce
sera le 14 octobre
allez j'ai envie de profiter la dernière
minute qui nous reste hubert pour que
les yeux dans les yeux vous me disiez
que vous êtes arrivé à convaincre quand
d'autres artistes d'autres d'autres
stars comme vous l'avez déjà fait ici
parce que on a du mal à l'imaginer mais
sur cette pelouse ya déjà eu plus de
vingt mille personnes
oui avec david gilmour l'emblématique
guitariste des pink floyd
donc là vraiment c'était inoubliable
pour ceux qui ont participé
mais ça restera pas unique effectivement
il ya des projets à venir
voilà on y travaille on y travaille en
2010 neuf ans fera sur cette pelouse par
exemple le aux stocks comme voilà le
voilà un scoop merci journal parrainage
de michael lang qui a été l'organisateur
de woodstock du vrai de 69
donc il nous a aimablement donné son
parrainage pour une grande commémoration
de woodstock à la saline royale en 2019
bon un très très grand moment vous avez
un site internet qui est très bien fait
si on veut en savoir beaucoup plus sur
la saline royale d'arc et senans sachant
évidemment qu'on a fait que survoler
très modestement mais très rapidement
grâce au vent qui nous a bien poussés
ce matin c'est tendre magnifique dans le
doubs merci nous avons accueillir une
bertha si merci aussi à vous dominique
landucci asociaux n'abusez pas trop du
pont quand même dans un dé attention
vous voilà et puis rendez vous pour le
spectacle du 20 juillet au 18 août
évidemment le spectacle s'appelle luxe
salina à partir de 22h30 voilà et merci
à vous un nicolas le jardinier d'autres
conseils très bientôt forcément ça c'est
sûr ce qui est sûr aussi c'est qu'on va
retrouver catherine rock maintenant pour
les titres de l'actualité sur france 3
dans votre matinale
bonjour à tous en franche comté les
professionnels du comté ont rendez vous
cet après midi à poligny dans le jura
pour réfléchir au futur cahier des
charges de leur filière c'est un rendez
vous important car le mode de production
de ce fromage obéit à des règles
strictes sur la nourriture la traite ou
encore l'affinage le tout contribue à
faire du conte est un produit réputé
mais surtout une réussite économique
un équilibre que les producteurs ne
veulent surtout pas mettre en danger
explications à midi des enjeux de cette
réunion
vous verrez aussi qu'il n'y a pas d'âge
pour vibrer devant les rencontres de la
coupe du monde de football
pour suivre les matchs il y à des écrans
partout dans les bars dans les
entreprises à mèche dans le haut doubs
il y en a aussi à l'ehpad devant lequel
les résidents se retrouvent pour chaque
match disputé en russie pronostic
analyses et commentaires vont bon train
pour ces amateurs éclairés de ballon
rond d'ailleurs david sandona a
recueilli leurs impressions écoutez vous
avez vu tous les matchs quasiment quelle
est l'équipe qui nous a le plus
impressionné à la croatie puis les
mexicains qui court comme les y est rare
et niveau 1
selon vous ces deux équipes 3 aciers
mexique peut faire quelque chose à
craindre
ils sont à craindre oui la coupe du
monde ça leur apporte un petit peu de
souris un petit peu de deux moments
partagés de bons temps de plaisir qui
fait qu on vous emmène un peu plus de
vie en bourgogne de son nombre
d'artisans du monde se retrouvent
pendant trois jours au lycée de challuy
dans la nièvre pour l'assemblée générale
de leur association
elle a été créée il ya 44 ans elle est
devenue depuis le premier réseau de
commerce équitable en france avec plus
de 160 points de vente dont une dizaine
dans notre région plusieurs ateliers
seront proposés aux participants
notamment sur la redynamisation des
centres villes où la vente en ligne
on termine en musique avec les rendez
vous aux jardins organisé comme chaque
année et comme il se doit dans les
jardins du conseil départemental de côte
d'or à dijon en tête d'affiche ce soir
avec d'autres artistes mais la tête
d'affiche ce sera axel bauer que vous
voyez sur ces images en répétition
à cons un concert gratuit qui permettra
de découvrir les titres de ses derniers
albums
axel bauer sera l'invité de marie joly
dans le journal de midi on le retrouve
tout à l'heure on l'écouté puis on
repart à marquer ce nom avec pascal
gervais
[Musique]
un grand merci à toutes les équipes de
france 3 j'espère que nous vous aurons
donné envie de visiter ce lieu unique au
monde
inscrit au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco avec des jardins
extraordinaires la visite fut formidable
moment il faut venir tout l'été jusqu'à
l'otan parce que les jardins vont en
prendre plein de couleurs différentes et
de la couleur ayant droit aussi de lundi
à la bonne heure et de bonne humeur à
partir de 9h50 aux apprendra notamment à
réussir un cocktail pour que la paix
soit ça c'est bien seulement magique
parce que contrairement à ce qu'on veut
on n'est pas en vacances la semaine
prochaine on sera là avec toute l'équipe
a bientôt france à bientôt pascal
bientôt revoir cette émission sur france
inter paris
[Musique]